in the heart of new york sits the
legendary big alice
once the world's largest generator of
electricity its owner
rise light and power now wants to make
it the cleanest by building the largest
battery facility in the country here
a 316 megawatt storage facility for
renewable energy
what are the challenges that you face to
meet this
deadline in terms of ceo clint plummer
acknowledges
it won't be easy our challenge is new
york's challenge and it's also the
country's challenge and the world's
challenge is how do we transition from a
economy a city that's run primarily on
fossil fuels for as long as we've had
electricity to one that's focusing on
now running on clean energy
infrastructure that's how you make
electricity take a large electromagnet
and you spin it the batteries will
replace their dirtiest
carbon spewing oil and gas fire
generators
the ones they rely on to power new york
city in high demand periods like a heat
wave
the plan is to connect them to wind and
solar farms proposed for construction
outside the city
new york is attempting to wean itself
off of fossil fuels
at the same time it's taking another
major source of carbon-free electricity
offline the indian point nuclear power
plant
in 2019 this facility alone was
responsible for 13
of the state's power unlike fossil fuels
nuclear power emits no carbon
and no smog and unlike renewables like
solar and wind it is not intermittent
it's reliable
pro-nuclear power environmentalists say
batteries
aren't yet up to the task of replacing
fossil fuels
the group nuclear new york calculates it
will take a wind farm larger than new
york city
to replace the energy generated by
indian point alone
the amount of electricity that it will
store
is 30 minutes of new york city's
energy need so if you think about
the amount of solar or wind that you
hypothetically feed to that battery
to feed new york city
like where are you going to put it
natural gas facilities are expected to
make up the difference
resulting in an increase in carbon
emissions in the short term
still others say the switch to
renewables can't wait
i think we're going to see uh
technological innovation
uh that is difficult to imagine
uh but it's going to happen because we
really have no choice
and we're really on that path now the
path may be uncertain
but in new york the goal of eliminating
carbon emissions at least
is no longer up for debate kristen
sulumi al jazeera
new york